je suis européen je suis français et je
pense que je suis l'un et l'autre depuis
toujours je me suis sentie européenne
pour la première fois à l'âge de 10 ans
quand j'ai vu le mur de berlin
s'écroulait s'effondrer avec beaucoup
d'émotion je voyais des gens se
retrouver et je me suis dit que
finalement l'union européenne c'était ça
c'était rassembler les peuples la
première fois que le suspect européen
c'est le moment où je suis rendu compte
qu'il n'y avait pas que la france dans
le monde le jour je me suis sentie
européenne pour la première fois j'étais
très jeune sur la grand place de béthune
au pied du beffroi y avait un festival
folklorique européen je me suis dit
l'europe c'est magnifique c'est de la
couleur c'est la diversité c'est des
chants des danses quand j'étais enfant
en fait j'ai la chance d'habiter en
région frontalière je suis à 15
kilomètres de la suisse à 40 km de
l'allemagne et là je me suis dit tiens à
deux pas de chez moi il ya des gens qui
sont pas exactement pareil que moi
j'habite à cracovie donc moi l'europe
c'est tous les jours c'est les conflits
européens c'est dans la famille
finalement ce serait peut-être pas si
bête que ça de pouvoir s'entendre les
moments qui a frappé ma vie a frappé
toutes les générations c'est lé 9
novembre 1989 la télévision italienne
nous annonce que les murs de berlin
avait jeté j'ai compris qu'il y avait
quelque chose d'énorme qui était en
train de se passer pour les européens et
pour le monde entier donc j'ai commencé
à appeler au téléphone mes amis on
apprenne voiture et on est allé à berlin
tout juste après la chute du mur et j'ai
quoi que ça c'était un moment que je
n'oublierai jamais qui a fait partir le
même engagement en tant que citoyen est
aujourd'hui en tant que personnes
engagées en politique le sentiment
d'être européenne
je lui extrêmement fortement puisse
traiter mon premier vote la première
fois qu'on a voté en 1979 pour le
parlement européen donc je ne pouvais
pas imaginer
plus beau projet pour me sentir
européenne pas pour moi le sentiment
européen il est né relativement tôt il
est assise naturelle
puisque je suis vraiment né en allemagne
de parents allemands mais qu'il n'ait
d'éducation allemande une formation
allemande et aujourd'hui je suis députée
française à l'assemblée nationale quand
je suis arrivé en france est à 38 ans ça
n'aurait pas pu être possible dans ma
tendre enfance il y avait une cérémonie
qui compte énormément c'est d'aller au
monument aux morts le 11 novembre mon
grand père était était mort à la guerre
14 et mon père m'a dit plus jamais ça
alors à ce moment là vous comprenez
pourquoi parce que ça touche votre
famille et quand vous voyez sur la
colonne de votre village
tous les membres des familles des
voisins que le connaissent et qui sont
morts ou dit plus jamais ça nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup de lieux de mémoire
aussi dans l'union européenne et de
temps en temps il faudrait qu'on se
rappelle d'où on vient quel chemin en
fait on a parcouru je crois qu'il faut
qu'on se souvienne qu'est ce que c'est
l'europe c'est pas un traité
international c'est beaucoup beaucoup
plus profond c'est vraiment des ennemis
héréditaires qui ont décidé de vivre
ensemble quand l'histoire avec un grand
h
rencontre l'histoire de votre famille eh
bien c'est la connaissent et de
conviction et l'attachement au projet
européen tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui
j'ai deux petits enfants franco
espagnole alors je le vis vraiment parmi
trip cette europe moi je suis allé
demander la main de ma femme en
septembre 89 en vélo de metz à cracovie
je pensais pas que je raconterai ça
aujourd'hui il y avait encore le rideau
de fer et comme je dis souvent je suis
passé tellement vite que le mur est
tombé puisque le mur est tombé dans les
trois mois après j'aime bien cette
notion de gradient de frontières de
considérer que les frontières seront des
espaces et plus des murs on sent
vraiment repères parce qu'on va passer
des frontières facilement parce qu'on a
eu besoin que de sa carte d'identité
pour aller d'un centre de traitement
parce qu'on travaille en ce moment sur
un numéro de sécurité social européen
l'appartenance à l'europe je les ai
toujours ressenti quand j'étais au lycée
on étudiait shakespeare j'ai lu don
quichotte quand j'étais aussi enfants
pour moi la culture européenne c'était
le liquide amniotique dans lequel je me
suis formé si je puis dire mon premier
souvenir d'europe il remonte à 1992
j'avais 9 ans et se tenait le référendum
de maastricht j'ai pris conscience
vaguement que quelque chose de très
important se jouer à l'échelle du
continent mais l'enfant que j'étais a
aussi pris conscience que l'europe
pouvait avoir un effet très important
dans mon quotidien puisqu'on avait
décidé on allait décider de se doter
d'une monnaie commune alors qu'est ce
que j'ai fait est bien j'ai
rédigé à la main un petit tracts pour
inciter mes voisins à aller voter j'ai
donc fait quelques photocopies que j'ai
été boîte et j'ai été distribués moi
même dans notre quartier c'est donc été
mon premier acte politique un acte
européen l'europe c'est une idée
formidable c'est très simple si a pas
d'europe organisés nous disparaissons
dans les 20 ans qui viennent si on aime
sa ville sa région son pays si on veut
plus de france il faut plus d'europe si
on aime nos nations si on veut pas
qu'elle soit détruite dans une grande
compétition mondiale qui n'est pas un
choix il faut une mondialisation
responsable humaine et c'est comme ça
qu'on arrivera à avoir une europe aussi
forte l'espace européen nous a conduits
à aller plus loin et plus fort on le
voit bien d'ailleurs sur les questions
de transition écologique on revient sur
la question d'égalité des chances
aujourd'hui lorsque je parle avec mes
homologues de différents pays on
s'aperçoit que les problèmes qui nous
concernent se pose de la même manière à
manchester à berne à apparier
assoyez vous est donc là ce sentiment
européen c'est de se dire nous avons les
mêmes problèmes nous pouvons avoir les
mêmes solutions
retroussons les manches ensemble et nous
allons pouvoir progresser le
gouvernement aux tendances à mettre leur
propre échec sur le compte de l'europe
moi je me réjouis nous voyons l'europe
comme une chance comme une opportunité
comme un débouché comme un objectif et
pas comme un bouc émissaire si
l'éducation périclite en roumanie c'est
notre problème c'est pas le problème des
roumains si la bulgarie n'arrive pas à
absorber les crédits les crédits
européens c'est pas le problème des
bulgares on prépare l'avenir de nos
enfants si on a une europe dans dix ans
qui est extrêmement dynamique mais qui
se concentre entre bordeaux et berlin
n'aura raté leurs feuilles je place en
premier plan de toutes nos relations
avant les relations économiques et
autres la relation humaine la relation
sociale pour maintenir et développer des
relations avec les autres pays si nous
voulons vivre en paix agir ensemble
vis-à-vis de des exigences sociales
éthiques ne se construisent pas
l'intérêt de l'europe des concurrence
économique des concurrences social c'est
un projet humaniste le projet européen
qui est un projet qui combine la
prospérité le respect des droits humains
la volonté de rayonnement des grands
principes qui doivent fonder pour nous
une démocratie l'europe c'est un projet
permanent et ce qui unifie l'histoire de
ce projet permanent c'est cet
attachement à la liberté cet attachement
à l'égalité à la solidarité désormais à
la transition écologique pour faire de
l'union européenne un continent qui est
à l'avant-garde sur tous ces sujets
l'union européenne justement avec ce
projet de paix avec ce projet de liberté
avec ce projet basé sur des valeurs elle
a un rôle capital à jouer sur la scène
internationale pour faire en sorte aussi
que dans un contexte qui est de plus en
plus tendue qui est de plus en plus
difficile sur le plan économique sur le
plan diplomatique sur le plan de la
défense elle arrive à créer les
conditions sur la scène internationale
du vivre ensemble c est pas pour rien qu
autant de gens veulent nous rejoindre
parce qu on a une richesse énorme ici
simplement aujourd'hui il faut aussi
savoir défendre cette richesse nous
positionner je pense qu'il faut jamais
perdre de vue le sens de l'engagement
politique pourquoi on le fait et pour
qui on le fait et quand on perd pas de
vue cette ambition là je crois qu'on y
arrive si nous voulons vivre avec nos
valeurs avec nos intérêts avec notre
influence avec ce que nous sommes ce que
nous apportons au monde il faut
absolument s'unir